Nicolas kirilovitz pour Radio sensation
nous fait vivre le festival côté
yvelinois ce soir et il revient sur le
soutien de la Région Île-de-France à la
production cinématographique une bonne
occasion pour lui également de se rendre
à la plage et de profiter le veinard du
soleil
l'île de France est sur la Croisette et
pour cause la région accordée l'an
dernier près de 15 millions d'euros
d'aide à l'industrie cinématographique
un soutien financier tout au long de la
création des films écriture de scénarios
réalisation et post-production cannait
donc un rendez-vous incontournable
installé sur la plage de la Quinzaine
des Réalisateurs le stand accueille
l'ensemble des professionnels comme nous
l'explique Olivier Thomas conseiller
régional d'Île-de-France ici on vient
naturellement alors on contre les
producteurs des réalisateurs de ceux
avec qui on travaille au quotidien pour
faire cette politique du cinéma qui est
environ à donner une création de 8000
emplois dans les en 2011 et ce qu'on a
compté sur l'Île-de-France donc c'est
énorme comme politique d'emploi pas
moins de 12 films présentés au Festival
de Cannes ont été soutenus par la Région
Île-de-France dans la sélection
officielle à la Quinzaine des
réalisateurs et à l'acide représentant
du cinéma indépendant parmi ces films
jeunes et jolie de François Ozon a reçu
543000 euros les de Claire Denis
466000 euros les appages de Thierry De
Peretti 50000 euros
grosse production bénéficie donc de ces
aides mais les plus petites réalisations
ne sont pas pour autant oubliées la
région on peut aider des tout petits
projets qui sont parfois aux alentours
du million d'euros et parfois on peut
aider des très gros projets aussi parce
que ils ont besoin de notre aide pour
justement
s'assurer qu'ils tombent bien en
Île-de-France et qui vont pas les
tourner en Roumanie ou ailleurs et que
ça maintienne l'emploi en Île-de-France
et à nos objectifs donc les projets sont
très divers en taille ils sont très
divers en contenu on aide aussi des
films d'animation qui coûte très cher
vous le savez qui mettent longtemps à se
tourner mais aussi des premiers films
beaucoup de premier film autre acteur
majeur francilien la Commission du film
est également présente au Festival de
Cannes son but promouvoir notre
territoire apporter un soutien technique
à la réalisation des films et faciliter
l'accès au lieu de tournage les plus
emblématiques écoutez Stéphane Martinet
directeur adjoint de la Commission du
Film Île-de-France notre fonction est de
faire valoir auprès du monde entier que
il est facile de venir tourner en de
France qui on y trouve des talents que
l'on y trouve des décors merveilleux que
tout le monde ou à peu près connait mais
dont les gens ne se disent pas forcément
que c'est évident tourner à Versailles
dans le château dans la chambre du roi
avec Versailles ce n'est pas évident de
s'imaginer cela possible nous avons
aussi pour fonction de faire découvrir
des sites un peu originaux qui ne sont
pas forcément connus du grand public
international et nous y aidons rien que
l'an dernier sont un film ont été
tournés en Île-de-France cela en fait la
première région cinématographique de
l'Hexagone prof de sa richesse
culturelle et de la diversité de ces
paysages